hoisting variable declarations and
function declarations are processed
before any code is executed so declaring
a variable or function anywhere in the
code is equivalent to declaring it at
the top this also means that a variable
and functions can appear to be used
before they're declared this behavior is
called hoisting as it appears that the
declaration is moved to the top variable
definitions are when you assign a value
to a variable these are not wasted to
the top let's look at some examples if
you look over here we have catalog not
declared if I take out this comment and
I run this you're not gonna see anything
in the console because this console does
not show errors and this is giving an
error because the this variables not
used anywhere in the program but if I
take out the content for this one
console dot log defined later as well
sure it shows undefined because this
variable
has been hoisted up see it's not
declared until right here this is when
it's declared but it's defined right
here since it's declared right here to
the program that's the same as it being
right above it so the the declarations
are always moved to the top so it still
knows that defined later exists but it's
not defi until down here so it's
undefined but if I take the comment off
of this code and run it you'll see at
the weight it's gonna say I am defined
so then we get to this next consult log
which was already not commented out and
it's a defined simultaneously so we're
we're declaring the variable and
defining it so the Declaration the VAR
defined simultaneously that gets hoisted
to the top but the definition which is
equals I am defined is not hoisted to
the top so that's why when you run this
you look at the bottom it's undefined
because it has been declared but has not
been defined right take out this
and now we got we have undefined and an
undefined so this is undefined this is
the I am defined let's clear that and if
we go to the next one so if we call this
function do something else but the the
function is actually not declared until
after the function call let's see what
happens it says I did it that comes from
this function I did it so functions are
also hoisted to the top so it's just
like this function is at the top before
you call it now down here obviously
that's similar but a little different so
we have a variable that's declared here
but then it's assigned to a a function
so the variable will be the variable
declared the declaration will be at the
top but the assignment the function will
be after the function call so if we do
that it's not going to show anything
after I did it's actually going to give
an error and the error is not showing in
this console view but it's going to get
an uncaught type error function VAR is
not a function because function bar has
been declared but it's undefined to make
things easier to read you should declare
all your variables at the top of your
function scope so it's clear which which
scope the variables are coming from
define your variables before you need to
use them but define your functions at
the bottom of your scope to keep them
out of the way thanks for watching my
name is beau Carnes check the
description for links to more
information please subscribe and
remember use your code for good